good afternoon ndc
how's everybody doing out there
welcome you ever ask yourself what kind
of person goes to a talk called plain
text
well look around the room
yes welcome so this is uh so this talk
is it's either plain text or it's
there's no such thing as plain text but
when i put that in conference programs
you get a different crowd so we went
with the plain text one uh but welcome
my name is dylan beatty
uh i've been building websites since
forever been building distributed
systems since the early 2000s i run
versatile which is a a company i started
in january 2020 so i could do lots of
traveling this is the dumbest idea
anyone ever had and finally now in the
last six weeks i actually realized how
it was was going to work all along i'm a
microsoft mvp with the developer
technologies program
i run the london.net user group
i also once invented a programming
language in a bar as a joke that then
the internet got it and they implemented
the joke and now i'm the project manager
for the joke and the joke has a
reference implementation and a test
suite it is the programming language
called rockstar so uh now this is it's a
lot of fun you can write songs that look
like oh programs that look like heavy
metal songs but uh the best thing about
it is that since rockstar kind of went
online and went viral people on linkedin
have stopped advertising for rockstar
developers so that is my lasting
contribution
to the human race
now
there are two things i want to say up
front about this talk one uh there is a
bunch of stuff in here that i learned
firsthand from talking to people
traveling around
countries that used to be part of the
soviet union russia and ukraine and
belarus and uh you know what is going on
over there at the moment is absolutely
awful uh you know nbc and me and uh all
the folks i know are on ukraine's side
they are doing everything they can to
support it
if you want to help if anything in here
is like we could be doing more go and
support these people
uh this is paracru they are a norwegian
humanitarian response agency uh based in
oslo which is where ndc originally hails
from there's a bunch of folks i know
from ndc who are actually out there in
ukraine at the moment some of them are
doing stuff like uh splicing fiber to
help keep networks up
pardon me um some of them are delivering
massive bags of dog food to the zoo in
kharkiv because the bears in the zoo
need someone to look after them while
all this horrible stuff is going on so
uh i kind of i looked at the talk and i
was like do i want to take any of this
stuff out and i've left it all in so all
the stuff in here about cyrillic and
russian languages and stuff because all
of it was just about smart people trying
to solve real problems so i hope that's
going to come through in the way that
it's presented now the other thing about
this talk
i've done this a couple of times now and
i did this at nbc oslo back in december
last year and they put it on youtube
and uh people on youtube have opinions
and it's uh got quite a few views on
there it's got about four or five
hundred comments by now and uh a few of
them are people just pointing out i made
mistakes because yeah you know there's a
lot of research goes into a talk like
this and i i messed a few things up i
got some things wrong so i'm going to
incorporate those into the talk but also
there are just some youtube people like
this guy brayden best
who goes there's no such thing as
playing test of course there's such a
thing as plain text
plain text is bloodiest in the plain
text mind type or more generally without
special formatting using only printable
seven but asking guys with a few
exceptions so utf also counts suited to
the money the water is a bit so liberal
850 words later results in a long final
destination there's train of events that
ultimately results in aldo
schwarzenegger going back in time to
kill your parents with somehow causes
world war 3. i guess people really like
that meme or because you chose to put on
a foil hat and die on the plain text
isn't real plain text can't hurt you
hill
brayden put the tinfoil hat on but turn
it inside out so it keeps the crazy on
the inside my friend the world will be a
better place so with the preamble over
let's talk about plain text really like
are we really going to talk about text
for an hour yes we are because we have
this thing we talk about plain text
we're programmers uh we have source code
which is a plain text and we have yaml
files which are plain text and we have
json and we have html and we have
configuration files and xml files and
all of these you know the software that
we build for our customers has special
binary formats for you know business
data and those kind of things but when
it comes to us doing our jobs we just
sling text files around and you know
saying to a programmer hey you know what
do you think do you like text like i
guess i don't know like you know does
the question really make sense but it
turns out that the things that make
computers cool and valuable and
interesting and exciting are that we can
take an idea a concept a word a piece of
media some music or you know anything
and we can encode that and put it into
technology and the technology can do
something with it it can uh maybe it can
send it to australia maybe it can put it
on disk so we can go and read it again
later maybe it can sort it for you in
alphabetical order or it can look for
discrepancies it can look for patterns
but then at the other end
we get the information back out and
somebody else can share in that initial
value that we had there somebody else
can share in that idea
now
we humans we invented text writing
probably about five thousand years ago
in uh mesopotamia and what is now iraq
because we found historical records of
clay tablets and things going back about
5 000 years and uh we probably
discovered electricity about the same
time like there are arabic texts that
indicate people understood that the
electric fish in the rivers had
something in common with the lightning
in the sky so they were clearly onto
something there um but things didn't get
really interesting until about 150 years
ago when someone went hey let's take the
writing and the text and mash those
together and see what we can get and
they invented this
so this i think is the first electrical
text encoding system that was ever
created it's a thing called a cook and
wheatstone telegraph system it's used in
england
in about the 1830s and there's a lot of
things about this project which kind of
seem
strangely familiar so it's created by
two people uh cook was a business person
uh cook wanted to sell this to the
highest bidder and cook was adamant that
it should be easy to use and it didn't
require a manual uh wheatstone was a
scientist if any of you's ever used a
thing called the wheatstone bridge he's
the person who invented that and he said
no no it's okay that they should have to
read the manual this can be difficult to
use but we should give it away for free
to make the world a better place
so we've got the whole commerce versus
open source usability versus read the
manual going on in about 1831. but this
device was ingenious the compromise they
eventually came up with was uh
you had to read the manual to send
messages but to read a message from a
cook in wheatstone telegraph it had
these five needles across the middle now
this was a five wire telegraph system it
was installed in west london between
paddington station and a town called
west drayton which is near where
heathrow airport is now and they had
five wires running through the
countryside about 20 22 kilometers long
and to send a message you would close a
circuit so you're making a circuit a
loop that is 40 kilometers there and
back again and you would send a current
down that and these needles would move
and one would be the outbound signal the
other won't come back the two needles
would move and you would read off which
letter did they point at and that's how
you knew what message was being sent now
it couldn't encode the whole alphabet
there's only one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten there's only twenty
characters on here so they have to fudge
the spelling a little bit but anytime
you're banging your head against ascii
or unicode or any of the other things
we're going to learn about in the talk
i want you to think we could have ended
up with this
we could have ended up with a five
symbol trinary encoding system where
every letter is a series of five symbols
which can be positive negative or
neutral so uh i think we dodged a little
bit of a bullet there now
the telegraph system uh the same time
cook and wheatstone built their system
they put in the five wires after a
couple of weeks one of the wires stopped
working and they're like we need to fix
the wire so no no come on let's build a
four wire telegraph system and then they
lost another wire and they're like how
about a three wire telegraph system but
across the other side of the atlantic
there's a guy called samuel moss who was
doing what we call leapfrogging which is
where you ignore the next generation of
tech and you focus now on delivering the
things going to come after it and he
invented the single wire telegraph
system
and he invented an encoding system to go
with it now this is uh
this is not actually the morse code that
samuel morse invented samuel morris
invented the single wire telegraph he
invented the first version of this
coding system it came across to europe
as a german engineer called friedrich
gerker actually standardized it and
that's the one that some of you probably
still familiar with today international
morse code now morse code
looks like a binary encoding system you
look at it at glance you like dots and
dashes that's fine but actually there's
more to it than that because most code
has dots and dashes and it's got short
gaps medium gaps and long gaps and so
it's actually a time-based encoding
system and
morse code was established it was agreed
as a standard in 1865 there was an
international telecoms conference in
paris and all the countries in europe
that were getting telegraph networks
were like yeah we're going to use this
this is the standard we're going to
agree on
now
as i'm sure you all know because you
work in tech if nobody is using your
system you can change it whenever you
want because nobody cares if you have
users you are not allowed to change
things because the users get upset and
so international morse code was being
used by the entire telegraph network
right across um europe down through asia
the middle east as far out as australia
changing it would have been a big deal
and so it lasted almost exactly a
hundred years it wasn't until the 1960s
that finally the world started going
maybe we need a better system and the
reason was
we had invented electrical computers now
the system that was developed for this
was ascii the american standard code for
information interchange and you know
ascii was phenomenally successful when
we talk about plain text files today we
are normally talking about something
based on ascii as we're going to see in
the rest of the talk but the thing you
need to understand about ascii is that
it was designed when computers looked
like this and it was designed when they
didn't have screens they had
teleprinters so they would actually
physically print out what you were doing
and you didn't store data on disk or on
magnetic tape or on ssds those hadn't
been invented for a long while yet you
store data on punch cards
so when you look at the design of ascii
now there's a lot of stuff in it you
look at you're like really
like what is all this crap in here
you're like okay now zero the null
character any of you see c plus
developers you've seen null right null
survives today it's the thing in c that
marks the end of a string and if you
accidentally go past it then you can
hack into the pentagon and all kinds of
fun stuff brilliant piece of design
there then
we have start of heading end of heading
start of text end of text now
this was all the bottom block of
characters here these are control codes
for mechanical teleprinters it's what
they were invented for they were
invented to physically control this
piece of machinery with all the clunking
moving parts on your desk and if your
teleprinter wanted to send start of
heading you would hold down the control
key and you would press a because a is
the first letter of the alphabet so
control a would be that control b would
be that if your teleprinter was printing
stuff and you're like no no stop and the
text and the text you would press ctrl c
and that has survived today and uh you
know i had to press ctrl c yesterday
because i wrote an infinite loop and
some code i was hacking around on so we
have these little relics from the days
of teleprinters that still crop up all
over the place um end of transmission
inquiry acknowledgment yeah no big deal
um bell if you go on a windows machine
and you type echo space control g and
you press enter it will play ta-da dot
web because that's how it interprets the
i want to physically ring the bell on my
teleprinter um backspace if your
backspace key is broken you can do
backspace by pressing ctrl h on most
terminals because that's the same
control code and then we get into the
tabs the line feeds the vertical tab the
form feed the carriage return now a
vertical tab is hilarious because it
says move the teleprinter vertically
until you hit the next metal tab stop so
if anyone ever says tabs versus spaces
tell them you indent your code with
vertical tabs and watch as they go and
look it up and try and figure it out but
the reason why we had these characters
is a mechanical teleprinter used a thing
called a carriage and in order to print
text
the carriage would print something and
then you would return the carriage to
the start of the line that's a carriage
return and then you would feed the paper
through to the next line carriage return
line feed made sense now teleprinters
were a little bit simple and if you
wanted to do bold what you had to do was
return the carriage and then you printed
the same line again and it wouldn't over
print exactly so you could get the
pseudo bold effect so carriage return on
its own was useful
line feed on its own
not so much there were very few
scenarios where you wanted to move to
the next line without getting to the
beginning of the next character now
this has survived today if you run
devices whose ancestry is based on unix
uh so mac os linux android devices they
use a single new line as a line feed
that's the end of a line in a text file
and the reason is that they evolved from
unix and unix evolved from a system
called multix and multix was the first
computer system ever that had device
drivers it's the first thing ever where
they had a way of running a little piece
of software that sat between your
operating system and the physical
hardware on your desk and so they had a
place where they could put in this hack
to say if you see a new line that means
also do a carriage return and translate
that character and go to the start of
the next line windows
11 has evolved from windows 10 from
windows 8 7
5 xp vista 3.1 all the way back to
ms-dos which evolved from cpm which was
designed to run on really cheap mini
computers that did not have device
drivers and so for those early early
systems which are ancestors of microsoft
windows you had to send a carriage
return on a line feed otherwise your
return your carriage would fall off the
end of your teleprinter
now
there are some very neat ideas in the
next block of ascii here one of the
decisions that the designers of ascii
had to make is they're like what
punctuation do we actually need
now if any of you here have worked in
printer and type setting um we have a
minus sign and we have a hyphen and we
have an n dash and we have an m dash and
these are all different characters if
you are printing books and printing
scientific papers the creators of ascii
were like now we don't actually have
space for all of these they kind of look
the same anyway we're just minus sign is
a hyphen is a dash that can double up on
all those but within the last couple of
a couple of years maybe the last decade
or so we've started seeing a resurgence
of digital typography because we have
retina displays and we have people
reading books on kindles and ipads and
so we're starting to see things like you
know smart curly quotes and typographers
dashes and these things coming back in
now
this block here the decimal digits one
of the most common things that you had
to do on a computer was to turn a number
into the string that represents that
number and back again and the way you do
this in ascii is you just ignore the top
half you take the bottom four bits of
that number and that is the numeric
value of the digit that it represents
and this was blisteringly quick even on
a four bit processor this was really
really quick and easy to do now if you
ever look to ascii and thought why is
uppercase a 65 and lowercase a is 97 why
would they have picked those numbers to
represent the beginning of the latin
alphabet well it turns out that
those differ by a single bit
so if you want to do a case insensitive
string comparison in ascii all you do is
you ignore the sixth bit and then the
values of those are the same and so you
can collate based on the the
numeric value that you have left finally
we mop up a little bit more punctuation
and we get to character number 127 right
down the end here and that is delete one
one one one one one
uh do you know why that is delete
imagine you're storing data on a punch
card and uh you've punched some holes in
it that represent your bank records and
now you're like i need to erase the bank
records now you could take the card
outside and burn it or you can punch
through the rest of the holes so you
can't see what the data on the in the
first place was um now at this point
youtube steps in and says delete was
never intended for punch cards and i dug
into this and actually it turns out that
right if you deleted a punch card you
ended up with a thing called the lace
card which would fall apart and jam up
your mainframe and everyone would be
very unhappy with you um so yeah pretty
pretty please with sugar on it if you're
going to talk about computing history do
your research thank you youtube they're
right i was wrong it was actually for
these it was for erasing paper tape so
delete was predominantly used for and if
you look at the left hand side of the
teleprinter there you can actually see a
paper tape punch machine on the left
there so
america pats itself on the back they're
like that's it 127 characters is all
you're ever going to need and they give
themselves yeah we fixed the problem of
encoding text and the rest of the world
goes sorry you did what
like
we can't use this you can't you haven't
even read any of our alphabet now for
some cultures
ascii was a complete non-starter i think
for most cultures you know um chinese
japanese kanji korean thai vietnamese
arabic cyrillic there are cultures that
are thousands of years old all over this
planet for whom ascii was like all right
you kids have fun this isn't going to
work for us
but for quite a lot of cultures ascii
was sort of almost good enough it wasn't
there but it came close now my personal
journey with plain text
started in 1988 i grew up in zimbabwe
where i spoke english and the currency
there was dollars and cents so when i
was playing little programs on my my
dad's amstrad it worked all the
characters that i knew about were in the
ascii that ran on the amstrad128 but
then i moved to the uk and i did some
homework on the computer it's a 286 pc
with a an epson dot matrix printer and i
tried to print this
and it didn't work
and it didn't work because this is not
one of the characters that the americans
cared about in 1965 and so it's not part
of ascii and now what had happened is
after ascii was published a lot of
people a lot of companies all over the
world they looked at this and went hang
on ascii's only seven bits is anyone
anyone using this bit
and of course nobody said uh there's an
international standard because there
wasn't and so lots and lots of different
people in companies they jumped in and
went oh we can use that bit to solve our
problem and this is if you've ever come
across the idea of something called a
code page
a code page is a set of rules for saying
what the top half of ascii means
on this computer in this program in this
document right now while i'm looking at
it and the reason i couldn't print my
homework is that the printer which was
less than a meter away connected by a
cable was using a different code page to
wordperfect which is what i was using to
to do the writing in now one of the most
popular code pages one that has become
ubiquitous was this one
this is code page 437 which was the
default code page on the ibm pc now they
kept the regular block of ascii the top
half there
they added
most of the characters that were
necessary for northern and western
europe they added box drawing characters
so you could do little menus and gooeys
and then they added half of the greek
alphabet
do you know why
they took the ones that were used in
maths and physics
there's not enough greek here to write
greek but there is enough greek in here
to do the most common mathematical and
physical formulae and uh they didn't
have a whole lot of space to work with
they could have put in the whole greek
alphabet but they want to we'll put in
the ones that are in the physics
textbooks and the rest you're just kind
of going to have to figure out later but
they also
said well we're not running on
mechanical teleprinters anymore maybe we
could use this top section for little
smiley faces and musical symbols and
this kind of stuff and if you've ever
seen an ibm pc crash really really hard
which they used to do quite a lot you
got a screen full of smiley faces and
playing cards and nonsense and that's
because the operating system was
churning out control codes which are
basically trying to say to the
teleprinter hey stop stop what you're
doing and the screen is going oh yeah
smiley faces how nice
now
there was a code page created by
ansi the national american national
standards institution for doing cyrillic
which is the alphabet used to write
russian ukrainian bulgarian
and it looked like this but it didn't
work very well because of a historical
quirk of encoding systems it was quite
common you would take a word like uh
privet which is hey hello in russian and
you'd turn this into this set of numbers
according to the code page but quite a
lot of systems would ignore the eighth
bit they would strip it off because
they're like oh no ascii is only a seven
7-bit system some things use the 8th bit
for
things i think word star used it to say
whether you had spell checked a word so
that they didn't have to spell check the
whole document they'd use the 8th bit on
a character as a flag for that some
places use this as archive but some
email systems would use the 8th bit as a
parity check so that would get lost in
transit and if you took this and you
stripped the 8th bit off and then you
tried to turn it back into ascii using
that code page
you got nonsense
and so the russians went well this is
clearly not going to work let's invent
our own system which is the code obnema
information vosimbit koi8 this is ibm
codepage 878 and this was brilliant
because what they did is they said right
forget cyrillic alphabetical order we
are going to take the number or the
letters in english which sound kind of
the same
and we are going to put those in the
appropriate positions so if we get
garbled in transit what comes out the
other end is something we can read
which i think is is rather neat now
there are some wonderful little
historical quirks and stories and things
um i did this talk at a community event
in the uk in october and someone came up
to me afterwards and said do you know
about the harry potter book i was like
what was the harry potter book and they
said so there's this great story like
way back in 2002 or something um there
was a lady in france had a pen friend in
russia and they were both big harry
potter fans they were sending each other
email backwards and forwards and i know
from the kind of historical record the
woman was called svetlana um i've made
up claudette i don't know who claudette
actually was other than a woman in front
somewhere and uh claudette said to uh to
svetter um you know do you want me to
send you the new harry potter book
because we can get it in france and
sveto writes back hey claudette that
would be amazing we can't get the new
harry potter book in russia here's my
address it's in russian alphabet please
copy it carefully and puts down this
which is a street address in in moscow
and sends that and of course vetter gets
this
on windows 98 running in french encoding
and goes okay well obviously that's how
they write addresses in russia
now this is the same set of numbers it
is the same underlying sequence of bytes
but it's been encoded using a different
code page so what us
claudette does is she very carefully
copies the email
onto an envelope
and puts it in the post
and somebody somewhere in the russian
postal system looks at it and goes i
know what this is
and they fill it out
and the the book actually arrives there
now
i'd like all you now uh get your phone
out your pocket if you've got spotify
apple music google play any of those
things i want you to search for this
word
on whatever you use to listen to music
and stuff just take a moment look that
up
what do you found
billy joel
billy joel live in leningrad 1987 billy
joel became one of one of the first
western musicians to perform live in the
soviet union and uh they played this big
show in leningrad and it was released in
the soviet union which was very unusual
and it was called concert and on the
cover of the record they spelled the
word concert in russian
and now at this point of course youtube
pops up and goes uh yes petrograd became
leningrad and later sang peterburg and
still one is today i was my best
knowledge but it was never spelled
moskoff i'm like who said musk off
nobody said moskov and the giant
colorful ice creams in the background
are actually the kremlin towers which
are in moscow and that's actually some
basil's cathedral it is in moscow and i
never said the photograph was taken in
the same place they recorded the album
come on youtube you smashing it today so
this album was released
as concert and then it made it across
into the us where someone's like we need
to put this into our database
okay i guess
and then streaming is invented and so
spotify and apple music they go to all
the record companies like do you have
like a massive database of all your
music and they're like yeah here you go
we made it in wordstar in 1987. you can
have this and now kohu ept is just
that's what the album's called this
weird encoding and transcription error
which is just going to be there forever
now now
code pages worked as a kind of a
temporary solution for a lot of things
but they weren't ideal they were clever
but you couldn't for example you
couldn't uh write a letter which had
hebrew and arabic in the same script uh
you couldn't mix different alphabets in
the same document it was quite common
that you'd write something you couldn't
print or you'd get something from your
printer that you couldn't load on your
computer and as we invented email and
the web and everything it became obvious
that codepages was not going to fix this
now
this is just
some of the set of code pages that
existed windows had about 15 or 20
different ones microsoft had some that
weren't used with windows ibm had their
own i mean ibm had their own alternative
to ascii which still floats around out
there somewhere
apple had their own ones there were
different ones for postscript and dos
the whole thing was a mess and it was
obvious that a unified coding system was
needed and so unicode was born
the project started in 1988 the unicode
consortium was established in 1991 and
their mission statement which i think is
a brilliant example of a mission
statement was just this
to provide a single consistent way to
represent each letter and symbol needed
for all human languages across all
computers and devices now this kind of
breaks down into three things first of
all
all computers and devices now the way to
do that is you've got to build something
that is better than any of the
alternatives and you have to make it
trivially easy to implement and they
succeeded you know unicode works unicode
is how um people on danish computers can
use slack with people on norwegian
computers and people on english
computers and people on russian
computers and we can all talk to each
other and it works you know it's a
brilliant solution and i did an
incredible job of delivering it um
but to provide a single consistent way
to represent each letter and symbol now
all human languages that was just them
going look we're going to do ancient
hieroglyphics we're going to do sumerian
because there's people out there
studying historical and dead languages
we don't want to exclude them
so that brings us to a single consistent
way to represent each letter and symbol
so what's a letter
you think these are the same
well let's start with these are they the
same shape
do they represent the same sound
we don't know it turns out the top one
here is harasso which is russian it
means good and the bottom is exoplanet
which is english and it's a completely
different sound and
so obviously
we have to agree what a letter actually
is now i'm british english so good
morning this is london here is the queen
would you like some tea that's the noise
playing in my brain all the time so when
i visit somewhere like denmark
and uh i see smurfaleg i'm like oh
smurfleg well my brain doesn't know what
those mean clearly they can't be
important let's throw them and somebody
has accidentally mashed together the a
and the ear let me split those out
and so my brain says this is a s'more a
palae egg
and i'm like
hello could i have some more s'mores egg
please
now this kind of gets us into the
question you know what what is a letter
do we is these letters here are they
just the same letters with a little bit
of extra decoration or are they actually
completely different letters
uh let's meet some friends of mine so
francois border is an archaeologist from
france and uh motley crue is a rock band
from los angeles
and uh this sentence is clearly an
english sentence francois the
archaeologist went to the motley crew
concert
but there are characters in here which
are not part of the english alphabet we
got the c with a cedia and we got this
little the ae which is a letter in
danish but it's not a letter in english
and we have the o and the u which is the
heavy metal umlaut um now at this point
i want to shout out to anders who saw
the talk on youtube with the youtubes in
it and he said i want to be in the next
version of the talk two weeks ago so hey
anders welcome uh we do actually have
when you read the new yorker magazine
the new yorker always spells the word
cooperation with an umlaut on it which
is just a weird stylistic thing so we do
get these letters you know cropping up
from time to time in here now
the ae there in english that's not a
letter in english it's something called
a ligature which is a typesetting
convention that back in the days when
typesetters made books using
hot metal printing plates they would see
an a and e they go oh i'll put in one of
the fancy ones for that and uh of course
you mentioned this on youtube and you
get people going not a ligature not a
ligature it's a typesetting detail
and uh so i did actually go and do a
little bit of digging and here this is a
font that i use which has ligature
support and they're kind of right the ae
here that's not really set as a ligature
in any fonts anymore but you can see if
you look at the difference there the ff
on the top they're joined together
that's a typographic ligature the ti and
the ij there these are different ways
but it's the same letters it's just
they're being printed differently now
let's meet another friend of mine let's
meet uh let's meet magnus so this is
magnus martin no this is magnus
mortensen and magnus is a microsoft mvp
from sweden a couple years back he's
traveling to the united states and he's
traveling on a swedish passport which
says his name is mortensen because it is
and the rules of swedish orthography say
that if you have ore and you need to put
that in the ascii strip at the bottom of
the uh passport so that american
computers from the 1960s can read it you
replace r with a a
so he gets a plane ticket which is not
issued by the swedish government and
they just take the circle off because
they don't know what it means so he ends
up with a plane ticket that doesn't
match the name on his passport
trying to get into the united states of
america who are a famously friendly
bunch
and he gets into a lot there's to answer
some questions now you know magnus is a
well-dressed affluent european white guy
on his way to go and do an event at
microsoft you can see how for somebody
else
that scenario plus united states border
control could have worked out really
really badly just because of a
disagreement about what a letter is and
how they get encoded and if you think
one letter is a bad idea let's start
talking about alphabetical order
so here is a list of european cities and
here is angry people on youtube saying
zurich has to have an umlaut on it and
here is me saying very sorry internet
yes i will do zurich with an umlaut on
it now
which one of these is in alphabetical
order raise your hand if you think list
number one is in alphabetical order
number two
yeah we got one in the back
um now actually i should put mine up
number one here is clearly in
alphabetical order because a comes
before b b becomes before o and o comes
before z now we got a couple of folks at
the back for number two listen number
three
and listen number four
yeah
now how can that be an alphabetical i
mean let's let's look at it slightly
differently how about now
now who thinks that number three is in
alphabetical order
yeah we got a couple of people changed
their mind on that alphabetical order
wouldn't seem like one of those things
that you can have a disagreement over
but it turns out you can because
different cultures use different
alphabets as i'm sure many of you in
here are very very well aware so we're
going to take this list of names and
we're going to put them into our
microsoft sql server database uh berlin
atkins zurich or houston herb
and we are gonna then do a select star
from cities there we go that's fine uh
let's select stuff from cities where
name equals or bro
oh will we put it there it was there a
second ago maybe it's case sensitive
what about orabro with a big o and it's
like nope that's still not there well
let's you know is is orbro even equal to
arab rule and we're going to run that
and it's going to say no
because by default on this installation
of sql those are not equivalent unless i
say to it hey i need you to compare this
word to that word but i need you to do
it using the latin one general case
insensitive accent insensitive collation
which is going to make it go oh yeah
well obviously now they're the same
so let's go back to our list of cities
here and now we're going to select
cities order by name and the default
galatian achen august berlin
herbroseuric which is you know what
makes sense to me as a british english
speaker but
obviously a lot of you didn't agree
because that's not the one you put your
hands up for what if we do the same
thing and we specify the latin general
correlation well we get the same thing
because that's the default but if we do
the finish and swedish correlation it
goes oh yeah well in in the finnish and
swedish alphabet the letter er comes
after zed so accion or host berlin
zurich and then er bro is the 20r is the
26th 27th letter of the swedish alphabet
um if we do it using danish and
norwegian collation
it goes yeah well obviously berlin is
first and then zurich and then urbru
and then akin and then orghus and you're
thinking
but why now
urhus the city of
used to be spelled
and then
in 1948 there was a thing called the
danish spelling reform so until kind of
just after world war ii uh danish was
spelt kind of like german it used the
german kind of german variant on the
latin alphabet and then for reasons i'm
sure i don't need to explain after world
war ii a lot of countries are like we
don't want to be like germany anymore uh
we want to be like sweden except not
quite like sweden we're going to use a
different earth
and so
there's three letters added to the
danish alphabet 1948 and any places and
people you know names of places people
towns those kinds of things the
convention was that you replaced a a
with uh so orgus became ortus and then
in 2011 the citizens of orhus went this
is really affecting like our google page
rank for tourism can we change it back
and they did
and so orgus became orghus became orgus
but it's still at the end of the
alphabet
for the completely obvious reason that
it's in scandinavia
and so it goes at the end whereas akin
is in germany and is not in scandinavia
so clearly that belongs at the beginning
now my exposure to this is i once saw
someone on a norwegian language version
of windows who had a text file called
aardvark and it was at the end of the
file listing and i was like why is
artwork at the end and they went outside
that's norwegian alphabetical order and
i'm like but advac isn't a norwegian
word
and they're like that's the problem the
computers cannot tell there is not
enough information in the word
for sql server or windows or anything to
figure out what local conventions of
orthography should be applied here so if
you do find yourself having to build a
system that respects local conventions
when it comes to alphabetical order you
can end up having to hack it and putting
in another column so you put in the
column that you show the humans and you
put in another column that you use to
sort things
uh i was on a website a couple of weeks
ago where i was trying to pick my
country and i dropped down list and i
couldn't find it and i realized
eventually that the list had been sorted
alphabetically in french and then
translated into english so great britain
was at the point in the alphabet where
ryan uni would have been found that took
a little bit of head scratching so
if you need to you are going to need to
put in enough clues that the computer
can deliver the result that the human
beings are expecting here and sure
enough you get out what most people
would consider in denmark and norway to
be at alphabetical order close enough
now
when you come across these kinds of
things you know like the little ascii
control codes and the weird alphabetical
order conventions
um
they don't make any sense at first if
you're just sitting there you know
you're on your computer and you do
something you get with weird result and
you're like why did it do that and then
you start digging into the history and
what you realize is that since we
invented technology really smart people
have been trying to solve real world
problems which are caused by people and
culture and convention and politics and
sociology and all these things that as
you know geeks well i don't care about
that stuff i just want to write code but
actually you can't write code without
understanding the context behind it
because the technology we work with
every day
was informed by solving problems that
were generated by these things there is
no such thing as politically agnostic
technology you can't even put words in
alphabetical order without having to
understand that world war ii happened
and that caused a bunch of stuff and
then some people voted on something and
that caused a bunch of stuff now
let's take a look at our see the the
little c sign here with a cydia on it
now unicode doesn't tell anybody how to
do their jobs what unicode tries to do
is to take everything that we were
already doing and come up with a
consistent way of encoding it so unicode
says all right well uh this character
here if you're french this is just a
letter of the alphabet that you have on
your keyboard so uh we'll give it its
own code point but if you're
english you are used to doing this as a
letter c and then you draw a little tail
on it with a biro so we'll give you a
unicode equivalent of taking a letter
and drawing a little tail on it with a
biro we'll give you a thing called a
combining character now the brilliant
thing about combining characters
is you can stack them you can take a zed
and you can go add one of those and one
of those one of those
one of those
one of those now on some devices what
you will get here is that your device
will crash this used to be a really good
way to crash android phones on others
you get zalgo text
which if any of you has ever looked up
tony the pony on uh stack overflow
you'll have seen zalgo text is what you
get if you try and use regular
expressions to pass html now
let's go back to our old friends motley
crew now the first time motley crue this
is the heavy metal umlaut this is a
thing that american rock bands do
because they think it looks cool and the
first time motley crue toured in germany
uh after the first show they're like why
does everyone keep shouting murtala crew
merkley crew
and
they had to have it explained to them
that in germany that says mootly crew
now we could write motley crue as that
or we could write it as that these are
both valid representations but are they
the same and again what unicode does
says well we're not going to decide for
you we are going to give you the tools
that mean you are responsible for making
the decision so unicode defines four
different ways of normalizing a string
there is a thing called the nfd which is
the canonical decomposition this means
you take the string and you break it out
into the
maximum number of code points if you've
got a c with a little tail you split it
out into a c and a combining character
the canonical composition is the
opposite if you got a c plus a tail you
can combine that into a single code
point and then the k stands for
compatibility because c was already
taken for canonical this means look at
the characters and they don't have to be
exactly the same code point but do they
mean the same thing and then there is a
decomposed and a composed uh
normalization form for compatible now
if we take a little chunk of code here
in dot net these are the the way
normalization forms are implemented in
uh in c sharp and uh we're going to go
through each one of those forms and
we're going to do a string comparison
based on that normalization and see if
the result we get is equivalent so if we
take uh these two characters here we've
got motley crew
and we've got motley crew using a
combining diuresis
and we're going to run that code and
what we get out is okay they're not the
same string they are not binary
equivalent if we just say does this
equal that it says no those are not
equal but they are considered equivalent
under all four forms of normalization so
we can say these things are the same now
unicode also supports fancy letters
we've got plain text here
in circles and we've got plain text not
in circles are these the same string
well again we're going to run this
through our little comparison code here
and uh out of the box it says no they
are the same length they are not equal
and they are not equal unless we impose
the compatibility normalization form at
which point it's like well that p and
the plain text in the circle that's just
the letter p come on we're going to
treat those things as the same for this
purpose here now
my uh personal experience with unicode
and character encoding uh all goes back
to one day at work about six years ago
where i got into the office one morning
and uh someone said to me oh dude i
think we've been hacked in the night and
i'm like now you get this all the time
when you work in tech right like i've
been hacked no you haven't been hacked
you've accidentally right clicked and
view sourced and put that away you
haven't
you haven't broken facebook it's fine no
no no no your files are on your desktop
look with that it's either behind that
window there you haven't been hacked um
but sometimes you know somebody who is a
really really competent security
engineer comes and goes i think we've
been hacked and i said why do you think
we've been hacked
there's chinese in the event logs
and i go and look in the event logs and
sure enough
there is chinese in the event logs now
we are a company of predominantly
english-speaking british people based in
london doing english language services
for predominantly english and western
european customers we don't have any
chinese programmers we don't have any
chinese programs that we know about we
don't have any chinese or no chinese
language support in any of our systems
where is this coming from
and
so you know we do the standard thing
right you uh start looking through the
firewall log see if there's any evidence
of a breach or intrusion you dig through
the database see if you can find chinese
in any of the tables is this an
injection attack you go and tell
business people that uh we are
investigating a potential data breach
incident and we'll have an update for
them in 15 minutes which means that me
as the boss can get a cup of coffee and
[ __ ] post on twitter
and that was the winning strategy
because i had the answer before any of
them did because i put this on twitter
and immediately someone says that looks
like a unicode mapping error and a fake
unicode which is a wonderful twitter
account that you should follow if you're
into this stuff says yeah the low bits
are all null this is probably utf-16le
being mistaken for 16be or vice versa
okay
yeah i should probably figure out what
that means
so i dive head first into the teach
yourself unicode in 90 minutes rabbit
hole and this is what i learned
if you take the word delete on microsoft
windows and javascript and java and it's
kind of most mainstream operating
systems they use 16 bits for each
character by default because it's fast
because you know memory is relatively
cheap and knowing the length of a string
by just saying well if it's this many
characters it's going to be double that
many bytes in length makes a lot of
memory management operations really
really fast so under the hood
that fact by the way is like 95 percent
true there are edge cases there are
exceptions but predominantly
internally windows javascript and java
use 16 bits for each character in a
string so the word delete
looks like this now if those get swapped
around so that the big end becomes the
little end and vice versa what you get
at the other side is chinese
and if you put this on youtube you get
helpful people telling you what the
chinese means
so that one is dismembering the body of
some livestock
the next one is to climb
there's a category of textile and
fabrics and uh gems and pearls and jade
formally put into the mouth of a corpse
so i'm like this is either a really
freaky ransom note
or it's a technical problem
so next question this is clearly what's
going on like you take the word delete
and that's exactly the text we could see
in the event logs so this is sql
statements being accidentally flipped
around we're like well why is it getting
flipped around turns out what happened
is that we had a like a virtual network
set up with a database a couple of web
servers and one of the virtual network
switches was about every three minutes
it would drop one byte
and it wouldn't tell anyone it done this
the byte would just go missing and so
everything would get shunted sideways
by one byte
without any indication that it happened
and the thing on the other end would be
like yeah delete from style where okay
chinese now that's fine and uh yeah so
that's exactly what happened there now
this uh utf-16 encoding which most
operating systems use internally on
desktop laptops local storage it works
brilliantly because it is fast once you
get out onto the world wide web the
balance kind of shifts because on the
web
bandwidth matters more than memory we
want to minimize the amount of data we
are sending backwards and forwards when
we browse the web we send email we do
all this kind of stuff now if we take
this web page this is privet which is
high in ukrainian this time and we look
at that in utf-16 now
all of the text on this page the things
that the humans are going to look at is
all in ukrainian cyrillic but this is
html which is based on ascii and ascii
only uses the 7-bit 127 character
encoding so these bits are the bits that
need to be in unicode and the rest of it
we are sending all of these zeros
that don't say anything they don't need
to be there now they do need to be there
because we take them out we're going to
get chinese in the event logs
but 44
of this document in utf-16 is just nulls
uh so html even if the language of your
documents is not based on ascii all of
your markup your tags your quotes your
html attributes all your css uh
hopefully your javascript if anyone
wants to write javascript in ukrainian
cyrillic it wouldn't be the dumbest
thing anyone ever did in javascript but
it would be in the top ten most of that
is still going to be ascii and so we
needed an encoding system that didn't
waste all this time on text encoding
formats which are predominantly ascii
based and so utf-8 was born and utf-8 is
brilliant the rule of utf-8 says you see
a byte that starts with a zero that is
7-bit ascii same as it was in 1965 so
all of the ascii documents from before
the moon landings those are valid
unicode utf-8 without changing anything
if you see a character that starts with
a one this is a multi-byte encoding
sequence
if you see one zero you are halfway
through a letter you need to backtrack a
little bit okay one one zero that means
this is the beginning of a two byte
sequence one one that's how many zero is
the spacer and then the red characters
that's where you actually read the
numeric value if you see a one one one
zero that's a three byte encoding
sequence if you see one one one one zero
this is a four byte encoding sequence
now they kind of stop there because the
longest round trip encoding we've got is
into a thing called utf-32 which is a
four byte sequence you could go higher
you know we could have utf-64 utf-128
this thing scales up to an 8-byte
encoding sequence but this gives us a
huge amount of headroom it gives us
space for all of the characters in all
of the alphabets that human beings use
or have ever used historically it gives
us a bunch of space so when we make
contact with benevolent space aliens we
can start sending email backwards and
forwards to them which i'm looking
forward to very much
and it gives us space to invent new
languages
and you're thinking we don't invent new
languages do we well we do uh there's a
new language that we invented within my
lifetime that most of you have probably
used today which is the language called
emoji is invented in japan uh about 1999
i was an artist shigetaka korito was
working on a project for tacoma the
japanese mobile phone uh like biggest
japanese mobile network and they had a
product called imode and they wanted
something that made like weather
forecasts and traffic reports look
interesting and so he created this the
original set of emoji which is now in
the museum of modern art in new york
and uh within about six months you
couldn't sell a phone in japan that
didn't have emoji because this just went
they absolutely loved it so when apple
launched iphone in japan in 2008 it had
to have emoji support which meant people
all over the world suddenly worked out
hey if you go into iphone and you set
your keyboard language to be japanese
you get all these cool little extra
characters on there so you could start
sending your friends text messages and
they come back how did you send the
smiley face how did you send the little
little grinning devil and stuff now
this prompted a lot of questions
some people are like well
why does emoji have support for like
sushi but it doesn't have tacos like i
like tacos where are tacos and other
people going okay pilot doctor engineer
these are all men
and they're all
this gets us into semantics are they
white men or are they yellow men because
neither of those is really a good answer
but certainly emoji was not very good at
allowing people to express their own
identity so uh in 2015 unicode took a
huge step forward because they
introduced the ability to modify the
skin tone that was used on things like
thumbs up and they did it
using combining characters just like we
did for the motley crew umlaut you got a
thumbs up plus this the medium dark skin
tone
would give you this
now every year there's a fresh batch of
emoji published and added to the unicode
specification and they have this huge
array of different you know gender
identities family configurations
occupations all these kinds of things
and the way that they do it i think is
brilliant because they use all of these
mechanisms that they built into the
design of the encoding system so the
unicode for female astronaut
is woman then a thing called a switch
which is a zero width joiner and then
rocket and if you send this to someone
if you send us to someone on an old
android phone you get woman rocket next
to each other if you send this to
someone on a modern android or iphone
you get female astronaut and you can
even add skin tone modifiers to it so if
you want the
official emoji of may jameson who was a
mission commander on the space shuttle
you send woman you send dark skin tone
you send a xerox joiner rocket and you
get that now flags is where emoji really
gets going because uh the flag of
denmark
is encoded using there is a block of
alphabet characters the regional
indicator symbol letters a through zed
and denmark has the iso code dk and so
the flag of denmark is the regional
indicator d regional indicator k and all
of the countries and iso that's how it's
encoded
england is not a country according to
the international standards organization
don't ask it's complicated
but the flag of england is an emoji now
they introduced a set of uh characters
to a unicode called alphabetic tags
which they put in in about 1992 thinking
this might be a good idea and then no
one used them for a long time and then
they took them out and someone went no
quick put them back in the flag of
england is using them because the flag
of england is a black flag followed by
tag g b e and g for great britain
england um the same is done for the flag
of scotland the flag of wales and the
flag of texas which is ustx is in there
as well those are currently the only
four but there is this mechanism for
putting in flags which are not countries
recognized by the united nations and uh
the pride flag
is a white flag a zero with joyner and a
rainbow which i think is rather nice
now does anyone know the name of this
country
does anyone know the official name of
this country yeah
which china
this is the flag of the republic of
china
not to be confused with the people's
republic of china the republic of china
is the country most people call taiwan
but officially it is the republic of
china and uh this flag
on the mainland in the people's republic
of china is a symbol of support for
taiwanese independence and they don't
like that one bit so if you go onto your
iphone in british english which is what
i have and you've been like hey type in
taiwan and pop there it is and you get
the flag come up but apple obviously
want to sell iphones in china because
there are three and a half billion
people in china and quite a lot of them
will have money to buy iphones and so
what apple did is they said all right
well if you go into your regional
settings and change it to china mainland
the flag disappears and it's not there
the flag of taiwan doesn't appear
anymore and it will never appear because
uh this is the deal that apple did to be
able to sell iphones in china is they
said we will take out the symbol that
your government doesn't like because you
think it's a symbol of support for
taiwanese independence now this was
apple's solution to it
microsoft microsoft went a step further
um if you go into my twitter profile
right now it's got a little danish flag
because i like the thing where you
change your twitter name to say where
you are and what you're doing and uh you
can you can see that now that is the dk
indicator but twitter's web interface
doesn't use the operating system to draw
emoji twitter's web interface draws
images little pngs that are part of the
website now if you go into edit my
twitter profile on a mac you get the
thing on the left which is the danish
flag on windows you just get dk
because windows has decided we are not
touching the whole china taiwan thing
with a badge for we're not going near it
there are no regional flags in microsoft
windows and there probably never will be
the only flags that are natively
supported on the windows operating
system are the pride flag
the skull and crossbones and the
checkered flag for winning a formula one
race so as far as windows mission
statement on flags gay pirates are
winning and everyone else can get in the
bin
which i can kind of get behind like that
obviously saves them a lot of
complicated meetings
now
i want to leave you today with uh
something practical that you can take
away and use if you have a look at the
logo type for my company and we touched
briefly on this earlier um the t and i
there that kind of stuck together and
this is that thing we talked about which
is a typographer's ligature and uh it's
still just ti that's regular 7-bit ascii
under the hood but this font which is
called lato will combine those two
characters and turn them into this
single glyph and it turns out
that we can use ligatures in programming
as well uh anyone recognize this
language
so this is a it's a very nice solution
to fizzbuzz the language is f sharp and
what the actual text in the file is is
this but this
same code same editor different font and
the font is a thing called fire a code
and fire code is a programming font that
uses ligatures and gives you things like
if you have the the equals equals equals
in javascript it gives you an equal sign
with three bars on it it gives you
little arrow operators it gives you uh
you know function maps and uh closing
brackets all kinds of things and i
really really like fire code there's a
couple of others this was the first one
there's now about 10 or 15 of these
floating around um
and i think they're brilliant i think
they improve the readability of code
they make screenshots look good you know
there's a certain like yay i work in the
matrix going on here as well
um so yeah if you want to get the
wonderful power of ligatures in uh your
code editors that you work with every
day go check out fire code download that
it's a font so it works with pretty much
everything any editor visual studio vs
code eclipse they all work with it and
you can get code that looks like this
now last thing that i want to share with
you today
is uh
i mentioned at the beginning that a lot
of the stuff in this talk is uh kind of
not necessarily stuff that i learned
traveling but it's stuff where i was
traveling i went that's weird why did
they do that that way and i went and
started digging with it and uh the first
time i went to ukraine which was in 2016
i was walking around the place i didn't
read any cyrillic like i started
learning the language the alphabet after
i got back so i'm wandering around the
place i can't read anything i can't read
the restaurant menus i can't read the
road signs but i can read the license
plates on the cars i thought that's
weird you know and so i started digging
into it and i discovered that uh there's
a thing 1965 actually the same year as
ascii was was proposed uh there was a
thing called the vienna convention on
road traffic
which uh all the countries in europe
they signed up to this thing like yeah
we will agree to play by these rules so
that we can drive cars into each other's
countries and stuff and one of the
stipulations of the vienna convention is
that your license plate could only use
the latin alphabet like the vanilla
ascii english alphabet now license
plates in the soviet union in 1965 look
like this
and i'm guessing that there was a
meeting somewhere where because the
soviet union signed the vienna
convention they're like yep we're fine
and i'm guessing at some point someone
said but uh what if you need to take
your car out of the soviet union and
they went to a comrade
you cannot drive car out of soviet union
but
if you did when you got to the border if
you had all your travel papers to be
able to leave they'd give you temporary
license plates and presumably if the
license plates didn't come back your
family went to the gulag so you would
bring your car back there um but then
when the soviet union you know kind of
collapsed in the 1990s all of the former
soviet republics ukraine russia belarus
they all overhauled their vehicle
registration system and so now their
license plates look like this
and what they did
is they took the russian or the cyrillic
and the english alphabet and they looked
at the set of not the set of letters but
the set of glyphs the shapes that exist
in both of those alphabets and that is
the subset that are used on vehicle
registration plates in uh this exact
subset is in ukraine russia is almost
the same belarus is almost the same but
this is the set of letters you'll see on
ukrainian license plates and if you
rearrange those
you get the word pike matchbox
so next time somebody says to you hey
i'm going to send you a file in plain
text you just say to them do you know
pike matchbox
and if they say yep then you're good
they know about big endian little ending
utf-8 udf 16 the history of ascii
cohuept character encoding cyrillic code
pages and if they say no what's pike
matchbox then they can send you plain
text and whether you can open it or not
is anybody's guess
thank you ndc
stick around i got another talk in room
two at the end of the day and then
tonight we are doing a sort of comedy
party show which i'm going to find mark
rendell now and we're going to write in
the next three hours thank you folks
that was a lot of fun i'll see you later
you